this is like a giant vacuum cleaner for
the atmosphere and it could be one
answer to slashing earth's carbon
emissions
we take it out of the air so we reverse
climate change
this system is cleaning up some of the
33 billion tons of carbon dioxide that
humans will release into the atmosphere
by the end of the year and the
international energy agency says it's
the highest concentration ever
companies are increasingly facing
pressure from consumers and investors to
reduce their carbon footprints so some
are turning to the carbon capture
industry that's forecasted to be worth
approximately 15 billion dollars by
2027.
microsoft and audi are investing in this
technology while coca-cola is purchasing
the carbon that's caught
we believe it's one of the solutions to
fight climate change but some climate
experts doubt the technology can have a
meaningful impact on the environment
probably one of the biggest challenges
here is having captured it what can you
do with it we visit one of the largest
open air carbon capture facilities on
the planet to see how it absorbs then
sells its co2 and how that could help
companies become cleaner
a lot of companies are trying to remove
carbon dioxide from the air some want to
capture it directly by attaching filters
on trucks and factories or by installing
ventilation systems in meeting rooms
here we basically have air being pumped
inside this chamber
but climb works takes carbon dioxide
directly out of the atmosphere we blow
air through this collector using a
ventilator
the co2 sticks inside this box and stays
there
natalie casas leads climb works research
program she says this facility is made
up of 30 ventilators that can pull in
about 1500 tons of carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere every year
inside the collector we have a filter
material this filter material is able to
catch co2
casa says the biggest challenge is
making it affordable to set up and use
building and installing just one of
these ventilators here at this facility
costs as much as two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars and it also needs a lot
of electricity so to clean up the amount
of co2 someone in the us would typically
produce in about a month that's
everything from commuting to work to
consuming food and watching tv the
company says it would cost around
anywhere from 600 to nearly nine hundred
dollars the target of course is to bring
costs down to bring the energy
requirements down and to make it easily
scalable
so cassas has been working on designing
larger plants that would use renewable
energy sources and require less steel
but one of the most promising ways to
offset the cost has been tapping
directly into the captured co2 climax
stores the carbon dioxide it collects
into these tanks then it sells it to
this coca-cola factory that produces
bottled water here recycle carbon
dioxide is injected in the water to make
it fizzy
30 percent of our production is done
with the recycled co2 from kleinworks
patrick witweiler oversees the carbon
dioxide project at coca-cola he says
early on there were challenges like
turning the carbon dioxide into the
right kind of liquefied form
we run a lot of tests and validations
just to be sure that the quality remains
on the highest level
whitwyler says using recycled co2 is
significantly more expensive than the
commercial kind the coca-cola is
committed to lowering its environmental
footprint over time he expects the cost
to diminish and that would allow the
company to expand the use of recycled
co2 from bottled water to other drinks
like coke
we're testing it and
we look into further expansion
making drinks fizzy is just one way to
use recycled co2 carbon capture startups
have also been experimenting with
creating fuel toothpaste and plastic
climax also has another way to profit
from the carbon it captures
the startup sells what it calls a carbon
removal service so that individuals or
companies like shopify and audi can
offset their own emissions you are
flying to mallorca and but i know it's
not so good for the environment i really
want to compensate you can buy carbon
dioxide
this part of the industry is booming and
fast evolving as regulators and climate
analysts debate how to best price this
type of service there are better ways of
capturing the carbon dioxide than
they're using sandra kentish is a
professor at the university of melbourne
who tracks and compares carbon capture
systems around the world she says it's
harder to absorb co2 from the atmosphere
rather than a direct source of pollution
the co2 concentration in the atmosphere
is only about 0.04
cement production as an example co2
concentrations around 30
so it's hundreds of times easier to
capture from something like a cement
flue gas but it will be for directly
from the atmosphere
this inefficiency means that to capture
one percent of the world's emissions in
a year climb works would have to build
around 800 000 ventilators but casa says
the company's technology can still make
a difference unfortunately the mass is
already here so we need to take out co2
and climax plans to take out more co2
with a new facility in iceland that was
built with some funding from microsoft
when it opens in september the company
says the plant will be able to absorb
about four times more than its swiss
facility but this time the carbon
dioxide won't be recycled it'll be
injected in the ground and turned into a
rock these are these white crystals
so this co2 is actual co2 which was in
the air
and this kind of evolution is how climb
works hopes its technology will become
cheaper so that it can clean the air for
companies searching for new waste to
reduce their own emissions
[Music]
you